This is your buyer.
And this is the typical AI pitch.
>> We're building an agentic AI
orchestration platform for enterprise
knowledge retrieval.
Okay, simpler. It's agents, but not just
agents. It's agents talking to other
agents inside a multi-agent workflow.
No, no, stay with me. It saves time,
automates the things humans don't want
to do. It's autonomous intelligence for
your workflows.
Sound familiar? This is why so many AI
products are in trouble.
>> [snorts]
>> Founders are shipping faster than ever.
Honestly, the tech [music] is pretty
epic, but you only have one shot to make
your mark. And in this market, that shot
lasts about the time it takes to ride an
elevator. Today, I'm going to show you
the three-part [music] fix for turning
complex AI products into stories people
instantly understand, remember, and want
[music] to buy.
>> I'm Veronica Hylick. I've built
products, made AI explainers that have
hit [music] 8 million views, and helped
YC startups, safety orgs, and AI teams
do exactly what I'm about to show you.
The whole method starts with one thing.
The wound. In other words, the biggest
[music] pain point. What is hurting the
customer? What is the exact moment your
user wants to throw their laptop out a
window?
>> Yikes.
>> To demonstrate their wound, follow one
rule. Do not start with what you built.
The very first slide of your pitch
should immerse people in their
day-to-day of their job. And show them
what they are already tired of doing.
So, a bad pitch, we built an agentic
orchestration SecOps platform for
enterprises. [music] Yeah, that's a real
pitch I've heard from a series B startup
recently. Nobody feels anything [music]
when you say that. Start with the human
moment. Security teams are exhausted
managing dozens of disconnected tools.
[music]
Alerts live in one system, tickets in
another, vulnerabilities in another, and
the real investigation is buried in
Slack threads and random screenshots.
[music] We fix that by putting it all
into one place. That touches a wound
because I understand the emotion now.
Overwhelmed watching time bleed off the
clock, making their lives harder for
absolutely no reason. And if your
product actually relieves that pain, now
I want to hear more. The format is
simple. In about 20 seconds, you need to
do three things. Identify the wound, say
we fix that, then show how. Your product
starts claiming [music] space in their
mind because now they can see exactly
how it impacts their day-to-day. Once
you've shown them the wound, your next
job is to make the product click. Here's
the test. Could a 17-year-old understand
what you do? If not, you're probably
going to lose the room. One of the
fastest ways to fix that is to tie your
product to a viral story people already
understand. Think about the McDonald's
AI drive-thru clips where it started
doing ridiculous things like putting
bacon on ice cream. You [music]
instantly get the problem, AI doing
something stupid in public. If that is
your wheelhouse, do not open with, "We
are an agent observability platform."
Say, "If McDonald's had used us, that
drive-thru never would have made it to
TikTok. We catch when AI agents go off
script and give teams a chance to
correct them before it becomes a PR
nightmare." Now it clicks because
[music] I can instantly see the value
your product would bring. And if you
really want to nail the product
storytelling part, ban these words that
no one can picture. [music] Give me a
mental image instead. "Devon, the AI
software engineer." Great. I can picture
that instantly. [music] Or, "We're a
smoke alarm for AI behavior." Also
clear. Those are not perfect technical
definitions, [music]
and that is fine. At this stage, they
don't have to be. They are the front
doors into the rest of the conversation.
[music] You can give the technical
version later to close the sale. Just
don't make it the first thing people
have to understand. The final step is to
show the transformation. This is where
you stop describing the product and
start proving its value. A lot of
founders will say things like, "We
improve code quality with AI." or "We
increase productivity." That sounds
nice, but I still do not know what
actually changes for me once your
product enters my world. Show me what
life looks like before and show me the
after. Before your support team spends
30 minutes digging through docs and
tickets, with us, they ask one question
and get the answer in 10 seconds with
the sources attached. Now I understand
the value because I can see the old
world and the new one. If I cannot see
what changed, I do not feel the story.
So, let's go back to that elevator.
Yeah, we already know how that ends.
Let's try again. Your team is wasting
hours digging through Slack, email, and
random Excel spreadsheets just to find
one piece of information that you need.
We fix that. We connect all that
fragmented knowledge in one [music]
place so you can search it and get the
answer you need in seconds. Same
product, different story. 15 years ago,
if you built something great, the market
might have found you. [music] That's not
true anymore. The products with the
clearest stories are the ones that get
funded, [music]
bought, and talked about. Great tech
that nobody understands [music] dies
quietly. Identify the wound, make your
product click, show the transformation,
then your idea won't fail [music]
because nobody understands it. It will
thrive and maybe even explode because
you can explain it in an elevator.
Founders, tell me what you've been
running into. Leave a comment with your
startup, and tell [music] me the biggest
problem you've had with turning your
product into a story.